Bentley what's up buddy
all right it came at you too fast huh
sorry yeah you did you cut me way too
fast how's it going tonight yeah yeah
um just getting a kick out of uh girls
who are quitting dating
um it's pretty funny yeah yeah as a
recently single guy and dating my ass
off having a lot of fun the horror
stories are hilarious uh as you know I
started my own YouTube channel here
shortly I'm trying to get some girls
together to do do that like tell it come
on and tell your horror stories because
is priceless
a lot of it is quite frankly guys don't
know what they're doing
they don't try you know they everybody
follows the old basic formula
you bore the [ __ ] out of them and
um
you know I end up ghosting a lot of
women simply because this quite frankly
falls on them they're uninteresting most
women nowadays are boring as [ __ ] well
most women don't have a lot going on in
their lives like you know they've been
told to be boss girls and professionals
and get degrees and buy houses and stuff
like that and they're just
anytime you know you'll sit down with
one of these
um you know professional boss girls
they don't really talk about much man
they talk about the nights that they
drink wine with their girlfriends their
favorite uh episode of The Bachelor or
whatever the [ __ ] thing is trending
right now right like that's why I always
tell guys like you want them to enter
your frame right so it's like you're a
motorcycle guy you know you say look you
know we're gonna go for a ride up to
Banff you're gonna wear this you're
gonna beat me here and you're gonna
block off six hours well what are we
doing where are we going how can I trust
you how do I know you're not going to
murder me and all that kind of stuff
it's like look this is what we're doing
you come along for the ride or not
that's it exactly but most guys are like
well where do you want to go to eat I
don't care well what do you want to eat
well what time do you want to go no no
it's like these chicks like they just
dry up so fast when these guys are
unable or incapable of like setting even
something as simple as let's get a drink
yeah
yeah you know be interesting be
different it's really not that hard and
like you say they you know they sit
around they talk about their box wine or
the latest episode of God knows what
which I really don't care
um
and they can't carry on a conversation
you got to bring that you got to bring
the entertainment man yeah yeah a lot of
times I actually had one of my boys
uh we were taught we were chatting and
then the next morning I got a text it's
like so what do you got for me today
what am I your source of [ __ ]
entertainment it's just language it's
like no like
yeah they can't carry on a conversation
they can't hold one well yeah
you can you can set up the date provide
the motorcycle and the excitement
you got bags on your bike right of
course
pack a picnic sweetheart
no it's already packed no no have her do
the work okay assign her the task
remember women fall in love with you
when they're doing things for you not
the other way around yeah so you know
facilitate the excitement the adventure
and have her do the work to go get the
groceries make The Chicory board you
know whatever it is that she's going to
put together in the picnic box and then
you know boom off you go so you know at
least she's got a task to do and it's
like okay well what am I going to pack
next time or what am I going to wear
next time sort of thing it's like you
know you have to make a adventure out of
it for because she's not going to make
it for you trust me if you let a woman
plan a date she's gonna come up with
some [ __ ] like going to woofstock
where you're gonna have to hang around
with fluffy white dogs and a bunch of
other nerds
yeah I'll bring Abby along she'll chase
a little fluffy white dogs yeah exactly
all right Bentley all right man thanks
buddy talk to you soon hey guys I really
hope that you enjoyed that short clip if
you did consider supporting the creation
of content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out